je vous propose un palmarès des arnaques
qui ont cours à l'heure actuelle et qui
exploitent nos inquiétudes à propos de
la commune de 19,3 arnaque on parle la
moins pire jusqu'à la plus pernicieuse
donc troisième position il ya le texto
de la croix rouge qui tentent de vous
faire fort que la croix rouge se lance
dans une grande distribution de masques
des masques pour tous les foyers
canadiens et vous invite pour vous en
procurer à cliquer sur un lien lorsque
vous vous rendez sur ce site on va vous
demander votre numéro de carte de crédit
parce qu'il faut quand même que vous
payer les frais de poste de 5 dollars
seulement mais ce ne sont pas vos 5 $
qu'ils veulent ces gens là c'est votre
numéro de carte de crédit alors ne
clique et surtout pas là-dessus deuxième
position il y a le courriel de mise à
jour de l' agence de santé publique du
canada on vous envoie un courriel avec
un lien sur lequel vous cliquez pour
vous tenir au courant des derniers
développements sur la pandémie
si vous cliquez là dessus ironiquement
c'est votre ordinateur qui va se
retrouver avec un virus alors ne faites
pas ça effacer ça les agences de santé
publique ne vous enverrons pas de
courriel et la première position
quelques heures à peine après l'annnonce
de compensations financières aux
citoyens qui en ont besoin par le
premier ministre du canada justin
trudeau ont commencé déjà à recevoir des
textos qui nous invitait à cliquer sur
un lien pour remplir le formulaire pour
obtenir cette indemnisation de 2500 $ et
si par malheur vous tombez dans le
panneau
vous allez vous retrouver à remplir un
long formulaire dans laquelle vous allez
devoir répondre à plusieurs questions
votre numéro d'assurance sociale votre
adresse votre date de naissance numéro
de compte peut-être puisque c'est
plausible que le gouvernement vous pose
ces questions pour que vous receviez une
indemnisation alors ne tombez pas dans
le panneau et je vous invite aussi à
faire circuler cette information là
auprès de vos proches surtout ceux qui
sont vulnérables
n'hésitez pas à nous écrire et aussi à
la facture et si vous avez été victime
d'une fraude signe elle est là au centre
antifraude du canada